at IMAX we have a long history of
innovation we're constantly looking at
ways we can do things better when it
came to the development of our laser
system we chose a radically different
approach than everybody else
in the industry we completely redesigned
the optics to maximize thermal stability
and ansi contrast and we did this by
removing the prism a component that has
been common to every laser and xenon
projector ever built we replaced it with
a patented IMAX free space light engine
incorporating an invar frame invar is
one of the most thermally stable
materials on the planet it allows us to
create sharper and brighter images on
the screen i Maxis laser system is more
than a handful of innovations it's a
reimagine a ssin of the movie-going
experience
this whole laser project has been like
getting back to our roots we needed a
test facility and we took over the
world's first permanent IMAX theatre at
Ontario Place it turned out to be the
perfect laboratory it had the huge
screen that we needed lots of space lots
of privacy one big advantage of
designing the system from scratch is
that we were able to get really high
contrast better than any digital
projector in existence contrast is the
difference between the brightest whites
in the scene and the darkest blacks
getting more contrast means more detail
in the image creating an elevated level
of realism that makes you forget you're
watching a movie existing digital
projectors have a certain range that
they can produce but the blacks aren't
really black
you can still see they're very dark gray
our projector gives blacks that are just
dead black they look like lights off in
the theater part of the attraction of
lasers is the color gamut right you see
enhanced colors that you can get that
are beyond the natural colors that exist
in the world with the lasers they're
very narrow monochromatic colors and we
can make those colors of red green and
blue ultra saturated the larger color
gamut gives us colors that we could
never show before either with film or
digital projectors you can expect to see
more lifelike reds and neon that
actually looks like neon with this new
system we go back to the roots of IMAX
and present audiences with that tall or
143 format
Beleza light source allows us to light
up really large screens a much brighter
and conventional projection light
sources and that's especially important
in 3d where the glass is often dim the
image by because laser light is
perfectly pure colors it allows us to
design glasses but actually it
completely eliminates ghosts
[Music]
[Applause]
when the laser system was being
developed we had engineers working in
tandem also developing a newer and
improved audio system we added six
channels to the already existing iMac
system two on the side and four in the
ceiling and what that allows us to do is
to create an even more immersive
experience than we were used to we had
more points of accuracy so we could pan
within the room having six additional
speakers because of the speaker
placement the tuning and the time
aligning we're able to create a perfect
3d space that allows a filmmaker to
place sounds anywhere in that space with
great precision we work with filmmakers
throughout the entire creative process
whether they're using IMAX cameras or
whether we're repurposing their contact
through DMR for picture and sound
what Laser does is is give the
filmmakers the opportunity to push the
creative boundaries of as to what they
can do and where they can take their
ideas laser really opened my eyes to
things that I didn't think we're
possible I've been a film guy for 40
years and just last weekend I looked at
two IMAX movies that were made 140 years
ago and 130 years ago to fly and Blue
Planet iconic movies and the power of
that machine is amazing things you've
never never seen before you can see I
think that we've hit it out of the park